pierre après pierre toute la nuit les
secours se sont activés pour déblay et
les décombres le 17 rue de Tivoli n'est
plus qu'un amas de ruines sur un terrain
difficile d'accès c'est entre les
immeubles voisins que cette pince a pu
se faufiler pour soulever des tonnes de
gravats un travail lent est fastidieux
vous le comprenez parce que s'il reste
des vivants sous ses décombres il faut
les préserver à tout prix et faire ça de
manière si je puis me permettre de
m'exprimer ainsi chirurgicale elisabeth
Lévy 20 secondes avant la publicité
trouve bien sûr Gérard Leclerc
mais je pense qu'il y a un moment où il
y a des sens aussi qui nous trouve que
c'est un peu une image d'Épinal que
Gérard vient de nous faire sur la
cohésion marseillaise moi je connais pas
mal Marseille j'y suis né j'y vais
souvent excusez-moi il y a une partie de
la population de Marseille qui ne
supporte plus ce que ça n'a rien à voir
tu es en train de devenir mais ça n'a
rien à voir Elisabeth pardonnez-moi ça
n'a rien à voir comme tu écoutes la
radio et que j'entends pas je vois pas
qu'est-ce qui est autour de la table il
serait pas n'hésitez pas monsieur le
chiffre un monsieur le chiffre est là
j'ai l'impression
de faire
engers
ça fait des amis je vous
écoute on parle à Marseille des
quartiers européens comme pendant la
guerre d'Algérie je suis navré de vous
le dire il y a les quartiers immigrés
les quartiers qu'on dit européens c'est
un vocabulaire qui moi franchement pour
la cohésion ça n'a rien à voir moi je
vais vous donner la plus non la
publicité je réponds à Gérard et ben
vous répondrez après la publicité je
vous le dis à quel moment on s'intéresse
à la vie de quelqu'un qui a 79 ans sur
la réforme des retraites de 70 ans
quel est l'intérêt de vous écouter quel
est quel est l'intérêt les écouter qui
est là d'écouter des propos de gens qui
ne sont même plus en 2040 2070
pas de souci pas le coup de violence
Jean-Pierre Darroussin Jean-Pierre
Darroussin qui a 70 ans qui est contre
la réforme qui a signative non mais je
me dis aussi pareil
je vais aller au bout je vais aller au
bout à partir de quel moment des gens
qui vont mourir dans une dizaine ou
quinzaine d'années ont-ils le droit de
prendre des décisions qu'en France on a
pas de pétrole mais on a le record du
monde d'endurance à l'accordéon chacun
son truc c'est le nôtre et si vous
voulez battre son record pour vous
entraîner cette semaine
ça me suffit faut quand même jouer 11
jours pour détenir son rencontre
les vieilles personnes qui votent
Emmanuel Macron qui s'intéresse pas
l'environnement qui nous intéresse pas
climatique qui ne s'intéressent pas à
l'avenir des travailleurs d'aujourd'hui
pour leur retraite dans 40 ans
en tout cas qu'ils aient voter
mais faisons évoluer la loi et mettons
plus de 70 ans
ne vous intéressez plus à votre propre
confort personnel qu'est-ce que je vais
dire parce que ça t'arrange pas
non mais c'est la vérité
Yanis pareil j'ai du mal je vous aime
pas ok très bien je sais pas sur quel
pied danser je suis en mode Just Dance
j'en sais rien c'est pareil toi je
t'aime pas et toi je sais plus où aller
non plus mais moi je suis eh toi tu es
dégueulasse toi tu es dégueulasse j'ai
plus de gens qui me suivent pas alors
vas-y vas-y vas-y je l'ai vexé en fait
sur mes conneries parce que pour
l'instant
c'est chelou
en plus
mariage et deuil on verra le bouquet sur
la mort de notre relation soit sur le
début de quelque chose
je crois que Jean-François c'est un
petit peu dévoilé par rapport à vous qui
est en face de vous à vous maintenant de
nous dire ce que vous pensez de
Jean-François écoutez il a l'air très
gentil
je sais pas quoi dire de plus je suis
navré il a une belle barbe voilà je
pense que ça peut être ravi parce que
vous iriez dans un jacuzzi gonflable
avec lui
pourquoi tu cries
de m'énerver
[Musique]
il n'est pas encore au point
mais il se donne à corps perdu dans son
tout premier balai
[Musique]
toi tu me fais pas du hip-hop tu fais du
prout prout
après tu vas peut-être trop crier ça va
mais rien à voir en fait toi les
émotions elles font ça pardon mais alors
toi c'est comme ça en fait bon
finalement on n'arrivera pas longtemps
finalement c'est
j'essaye de mettre un peu d'eau dans mon
bain pour qu'on puisse enfin se
comprendre tu vois ce que je veux dire
une antilope s'est lancée un défi de
taille traversé une rivière de plusieurs
dizaines de mètres de large
les touristes filmant la scène vont vite
remarquer une deuxième présence dans
l'eau
un crocodile a décidé de prendre en
chasse l'animal
à quelques mètres du rivage le reptile
tente une attaque
belle défense du cervidé qui a
vaillamment refusé d'être le plat du
jour
j'aime pas ta façon de me parler c'est
clair
[Musique]
il a beau sortir le grand jeu
elle en a vu assez
[Musique]